- Sometimes I get
so sad, you know.
(audience laughs)
I get so freakin' sad.
Ah, boy, I just go out,
look at my cool car, you know,
and I just drive.
(techno music)
(audience laughs)
♪ I'm Ryan Gosling
♪ I'm pretty tough
♪ But I ain't no
crazy cool artist
♪ Like Shia LeBeouf
Shia LeBeouf's doing it, man.
He's got it down.
He's super cool.
I don't know what he's doing,
but if you blur your eyes,
it's like is that Picasso
or is that the guy
from Transformers
Two: Dark of the Moon?
And I don't know why.
I'm just trying to be a
simple actor movie star guy.
Just trying to be
an actor, you know.
Real cool, you know.
I'm from Brooklyn, you know.
I'm from Brooklyn, Ontario, so,
that's pretty cool.
Everyone there talks like,
like this.
You know, so like
pretty much Brooklyn
except we say forget a-boot it.
(audience laughs)
But, you know, like,
growing up,
I hung out with Smitty down
at the mechanic shop a lot.
He was real nice to me.
You know, gave me my
first self-esteem.
He really was the one that
taught me how to drive.
(techno music)
♪ I changed my accent
♪ To be in movies
♪ I think it's
working pretty nicely
♪ So suck my dick
I'm sorry I said that.
That was a good show, right?
Was I good?
(laughs)
- It was great, dude.
- Thank you.
- You could feel
the anticipation
with the cigarettes.
- Thank you.
- Ask me a question.
- Camille,
what's Tuesday like for you?
- Tuesdays good.
- Ask me a question.
- Where'd you get this sweater?
- Oh this?
- (laughs) Yeah.
- Levi's store.